no no no no non vi tagliate i capelli
non vi tagliate i capelli posso aiutarti
Infatti questa mi sa che gli l'hanno
tagliata i capelli guarda
ti Oh cattivo Eccolo qua Il Barber Shop
dei robot e spia eh vabbè Google
Translate oggi affronteremo un nuovo
cattivo in una nuovissima Escape Room e
cioè il barbiere robot siete pronti
Mettetevi comodi Prendi i Popcorn
iniziamo subito la nostra Escape Room
pronta
vediamo cosa ci aspetta Wow Ok quindi
noi ci possiamo sedere tipo qua uh wow
ma proprio Uhm le maniche escono dal
muro e ti fanno i capelli loro Oh no
vediamo no no no no no no voi tagliate i
capelli non vi tagliate i capelli posso
aiutarti posso prendere queste forbici
perché li riesco io ad aiutarmi
Ciao che mi togliere i capelli Aiuto
ok Sono riuscita a scappare Cioè
praticamente Questo è un parrucchiere
barbiere che invece di avere le persone
Guardate quanto
è un'idea un po' geniale se non fossero
stati malefici e un po' come idea perché
i robot fanno tutto magari nel futuro
sarà così il robot taglieranno i capelli
Guarda guarda qui c'è tipo l'impiegato
del mese con la foto e ovviamente
l'impiegato del mese sembra essere
proprio un robot tipo la scrivania con
le mani così tanta roba Sì 3:52 però qua
si è rotta una mano di un robot che ha
rivelato un tunnel Guarda qua c'è
qualcuno Poverino
ma vi guardate Guardate come li hanno
tagliato i capelli e
Robotboy Hehe sta piangendo Sembra un
ananas cosa c'è altro qua sopra Vediamo
dei pezzi di muro che stanno cadendo
quindi questi robot sono cattivi perché
tu ti siedi ma non ti fanno il taglio
che vorresti ma ma sì oh ti tagliano un
forte tutti i capelli uh
ti vogliamo salvare se riusciamo a fare
qualcosa Guarda qua c'era anche la tinta
per capelli la vedete comunque è rossa
Cioè dopo avergli fatto la cresta
vogliono anche tenerli i capelli di blu
e rosso Ma poverino in realtà quello il
germicida Sì si mettono le spazzole là
dentro per sterilizzarle
ma solo dal barbiere questa cosa dal
parrucchiere non l'ho mai visto ma non
la barbiere non si sono mai andata
perché effettivamente non l'ho la barba
perfetta eh comunque procediamo in
questa Escape Room guardando lo specchio
però qui
ma non riflette niente questo Specchio
io non mi vedo perfetto
si è rotto Dai vediamo allora dove ci
porta questo tunnel scheletro lo vedi un
teschio Oh no Questo sarà stato uno dei
clienti che si è lamentato per il suo
taglio di capelli corti
qua ce n'è un altro anche questo
scappiamo oppure erano i parrucchieri
prima Cioè prima magari c'erano dei
parrucchieri sono stati eliminati dai
robottini sopra il vento Sì e ora
dominano il negozio di no no no nel
negozio eh E ora dominano il
parrucchiere barbiere che va bene
insomma avete capito Cioè non è ehm
Infatti questa mi sa che glielo hanno
Tagliati i capelli Guarda poverina di
tutti sì vai un giocatore o no non
capisco eh vabbè Mi dispiace Beh
ovviamente Uhm che Escape Room sarebbe
se non ci fosse almeno almeno
è vero Ho preso fuoco
Avete visto come ho preso fuoco Vitale
Cioè tipo cioè completamente
carbonizzato forse era tipo un vulcano o
no pure questo Poverino
Hahaha
mi ha anche tagliato i capelli
io sono riuscito a passare ma uffa io no
ancora c'è una grattugia gigante quella
è per fare un taglio molto originale e
il taglio grattugia capelli No il taglio
gruviera perché mette lì fa i buchi Uh
uh uh
vuoi provare magari un nuovo taglio che
ne pensi proviamo Io salto
Ma sei ancora indietro Tu dove sei Sei
caduta Ah ciao ciao
E scrivete nei commenti secondo voi io
Vitale dovremmo tagliarci i capelli
Vitale Sì sicuramente perché c'è questo
casco in testa che
sfoltire un pochettino e io dovrei
tagliarmi i capelli Secondo voi no no no
no no
no mi pare ci sono Allora i capelli
lunghi non vuole mai che ve li taglio ci
sono le patate twiste qua vedi non credo
proprio che siano patatine fritte Ho
preso fuoco Infatti io a pensare al cibo
ti ho detto perché forse c'è un po' fame
e quindi è per quello che penso subito
al cibo quando mai non hai fame
effettivamente la maggior parte delle
volte dipende il 100% delle volte
ho trovato del TNT che ho preso dove
l'ho messo l'ho messo qui dentro sì cosa
dobbiamo far saltare in aria questa
parte qui Vedi perchè parte sì Vediamo
Ah ah ah ah ah aiuto aspetta
uh uh non è successo niente Ehi Per me
sì ma io non l'ho messo ancora Ah ah ah
vediamo che cosa vedo per esplodere Io
non vedo niente
ciao ciao
Oh Che figo stiamo scappando da questa
torre con una corda Non ci posso credere
Guarda laggiù c'è il barbiere cattivo
forse lui è il capo barbiere
parrucchiere robot lo vedi laggiù la
faccia No non vedo niente uh mi sono
sfracellato Ecco così impari ad andare
velocissimo bisogna stare attenti questi
sono qui
sono pettini io pensavo fossero tipo
quelle cose dove passano gli ingranaggi
le ruote dentate tipo quelle cose lì
aspetta quel Barbieri il barbiere sopra
i no effettivamente credo che tu hai
ragione su quello che le forbici e Ma
secondo te no vedi quella testa laggiù
cattivissima Tra l'altro la vedete Certo
Secondo te ci mangeranno
Allora quando ci sono gli umani o gli
animali Ho capito però quando ci sono i
robot mica i robot hanno quella parte lì
marrone Marrone
preferita di evitare forse non ci sarà
ma magari All'interno c'è tipo delle
cose che ci fanno a pezzettini e ci
immaginano e lui ci mangia e poi si
sputa tipo Tipo macchina cartocciata può
essere Uh che è successo oh oh oh io
parlavo tu stavi scappando avanti
Perché in genere tu fai lo stesso mentre
io parlo Tu mi superi No comunque guarda
se
non capisco quando Eh no attento ti
sfracello
Ok adesso dai l'hai messo adesso andiamo
ah ah Ma com'è possibile stavo andando a
salvare Mi ha disintegrato ma secondo me
passa un po' di tempo prima che lui eh
Quello che stavo dicendo questo sta
studiando i viaggi
Comunque voi lasciate un mi piace se
volete che Vitale si taglia i capelli e
lasciate un mi piace se volete che io mi
taglio i capelli assolutamente Eh sono
riuscita a salvarmi l'ho sconfitto Oh io
te lo aspetto la luce che è successo
dopo che Salvi si spegne la luce aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
non farebbe nulla Ah dentro questo sto
cercando di rubarmi
forse riusciamo a sconfiggerlo da qua
magari c'è un pulsante per disattivarlo
Non lo so però è tutto fatto strano cioè
tipo le mandibole d'acciaio Eh
ma perché non c'è un pulsante per
distruggerlo questo Oh Spegni il robot
Allora dobbiamo andare avanti magari
alla fine delle Escape Room ci sarà un
modo per
sconfiggerlo Forse bisogna buttarli tipo
l'acqua addosso
si è spenta la luce questo mi fa paura
perché vuol dire che sta arrivando
qualcuno
ti avevo rigo che è successo ma io non
sono riuscito ad aprirlo come faccio io
il barbiere Vai tipo un Kart un
Caterpillar Che cos'è No no no no no no
cosa vuole fare
Ma cosa dobbiamo fare Aiuto no mi ha
preso riproviamo Non ho capito che cosa
devo fare Devo scappare prima che arrivi
mi hai spiaccicato lì per terra Oh no
lui esce da qua presto dobbiamo trovare
la via di fuga prima che l'aiutante del
barbiere è roba il robot cattivo arrivi
e noi stiamo a piedi e lui sta col col
furgone No io l'ho trovato forse Oh
aiuto
Vitale dove sei una situazione un po'
particolare solo sopra la porta e lui
con tutto il carrello il camioncino lì è
arrivato dentro alla porta e adesso non
mi posso muovere ti vedo là sopra Sì
esatto tutto il mio giro sotto Ah tu ti
sei messo qua sopra sì Eh ma adesso non
c'è nessun camioncino Guarda che bello
però guarda adesso arriverà forza anche
per te vabbè entriamo da questa porta
già che ci siamo non c'è scritto non
entrare Oh no ma è vero che anche io mi
nascondo qua come faccio io adesso forse
mi ha preso mi ha preso lo sai non è
arrivato ancora e non so che cosa è
successo Si è bloccato tutto io non lo
vedo più Però quello era la porta
sbagliata Ma quindi dove dobbiamo andare
Stai seguendo No no ma è velocissimo
Ok Ragazzi
riproviamo Fammi vedere tutto dritto
allora forse dobbiamo entrare in quella
porta in cui c'è scritto non entrare non
Guardate come vedete non riesco a vedere
niente non guardarti mai indietro
ma non si apre non si apre proprio la
porta ha preso ok
dove dobbiamo andare Allora Uffa Allora
dobbiamo prima attivare da quello che ho
capito da dove lo attiviamo deve esserci
un'altra porta qua da qualche parte
aiuto proviamo a salire qui Brava ottima
idea aspettiamo
si è bloccato
si è bloccato Eh ma forse lui aspetta
che non ci muoviamo Adesso vado che cosa
sta succedendo È rimasto incastrato
Forse era questo il trucco Allora
dovevamo farlo incastrare lì e adesso
così vado ad aprire la porta però
dice di non entrare ma uffa aprite
questa porta Forse lo dobbiamo fare
avvicinare lì e qui si aprirà la porta è
vero hai ragione perché è successo mi ha
preso pure a te a me mi ha messo dentro
una scatola Eh Okay Okay Allora proviamo
con l'altra tecnica Cioè forse è meglio
solo incastriamo Nelle scatole che sono
subito dopo no no no Fallo avvicinare la
porta perché quando lui si avvicina alla
porta si apre la porta che punto noi
possiamo scappare va bene dove ci sta
inseguendo o no Eccolo sta arrivando
presto presto presto corre ragazzi
corri non fermarti neanche un secondo
Okay
più lento ah ecco perché mi prendeva
allora Corri e basta ok Quando lui
arriva noi entriamo è arrivato
Vai Guarda No non ho capito Allora c'è
stato un bug non ci faceva passare in
nessun modo Quindi ora Abbiamo
ricominciato il gioco tutto ragazzi Ci
riproviamo allora E adesso proviamo ad
andare senza farci prendere in mente una
volta perché forse il bug E quando tu
vieni preso dopo non si apre più la
porta Quindi andiamo velocissimamente
scappiamo dritto no no no non ti ho già
preso no anche a me mi mangio pure
questo spostato nel muro perché vediamo
che si apre la porta Speriamo che si
apra non rimaniamo qua incastrato troppo
tardi sì sì sì
Finalmente siamo in un altro stage
Allora qui c'è il sugo con la pasta Ah
no no è proprio la lava Sì è meglio che
non la tocchi ma si vede che è ora di
pranzo che c'ho tanta fame
non c'entra che sia ora di pranzo qua
signora
Vedi quando pensi al cibo ti fai
registrare Troppo Peggio per te Sì mi
misuro gelato qui nel petrolio intanto
arrivo prima io no no no no no no no no
non ce la farai raffredderò per primo io
il mezzo no questa volta io le ultime
volte le stava vincendo Vitale Quindi
questa volta devo vincere io ma bisogna
premere il pulsante Qui sì luce rossa e
luce verde c'è scritto qua oh oh quindi
vuol dire che forse dobbiamo muoverci
solo con la luce verde
Guardatelo vedete quel robot
lì oh oh è gigante quindi ci dobbiamo
muovere solo quando lui ha girato vero
luce verde Ok fermo fermo È tipo un due
tre stella arrivo prima io arrivo arrivo
fa Vitale super in vantaggio
io vado giusto salvare un attimino qui
casomai mi succede qualcosa
dai Rita ce la puoi farcela dove sei
comunque
[Musica]
aiuto aiuto aiuto
ce l'ho fatta Ah Ah bravo bravo bravo
Adesso ti smonto
come hai detto prima buttiamo un po'
d'acqua magari tutti Vai in Corso
circuito Eh sconfiggiamo vai Allora ok
Dove andiamo adesso Ehm Che cos'è questo
stage ehm non lo so Un po' strano cioè
non c'entra più niente con il barbiere o
il parrucchiere Il barbiere Forse qui
nasconde delle scorie
oppure sono I coloranti per i capelli Il
rosso il rosso è rosso Ok allora il
secondo è blu No non è blu non è blu
sarà Vediamo facciamo il vostro
trucchetto
dovrebbe essere verde perché non riesco
a passare
[Applauso]
bianco
Sì ce l'ho fatta Ok bianco Salviamo
subito Oh guarda quanti sono tanti
iPhone Che carini come funzioneranno
Ecco Puoi passare solo quando andare
l'iPhone smettano di sparare le
bollicine
[Musica]
è difficile riuscire a non sfracellarsi
bisogna prendere bene le distanze e
fermarsi ogni tanto Oh Guardate quanto
Guardate tutta Ah ah ah ah Vai veloce ma
ti sfracelli anche loro bisogna fermarsi
ogni tanto ci troviamo
alla fine è vero ma sei stata bravissima
come hai fatto alla fine eh eh io ci
sono ci sono ci sono andata appena
arriverai c'è una palla gigante che
vuole schiacciarci ma sta venendo verso
di noi sì ma per fortuna si blocca prima
però secondo me sì accetterà un
pochettino e secondo voi non sapete che
era Vitale sta arrivando qui ma come si
fa ah ah tutti e due tutti
i pelati Tra l'altro dobbiamo capire
bene come affrontare questa palla
gigante che sta venendo addosso
mi sa che non ci arriverai quindi a dopo
Non avevo capito
capito come fare
Dobbiamo nasconderci dove ci sono lì le
frecce vedi aspetta Ora aspetto che vada
via allora
Fammi vedere dov'è Anita Ok via via
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
Per un pelo brava ce l'abbiamo fatta qui
un secondo eh Ma no no no no no no devi
stare dietro dovevi stare indietro dopo
che passa devi uscire dai Uffa ora devo
rifare tutto da capo
e poi vado nell'altra porta poi con le
altre porte devi fare il contrario come
il contrario
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto Ok vai dentro e adesso aspetta
Aspetta adesso aspetta Vedi quando passa
quando passa Vai nella prossima porta ok
Aspettiamo
corri corri corri corri aiuto
sei un portale
amiche!
il badge Belvedere dobbiamo aver
terminato
ci porterà vediamo vediamo vediamo dove
ci teletrasporta il prossimo portale
Mr Nightmare School
adesso si è attivato dove credi che stai
andando Anita Stories su YouTube Nella
nella classe cioè la lezione non è
ancora finita eh
caro mostro noi scapperemo Ciao ma tanto
noi abbiamo già collezionato il Belgio
di questa esperienza
e ora vi lasciamo qua qua Guardate
vedete che cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video
eh Buona visione Ciao